I'm an a journalist with a cause and
I've been so active against oppression
against radical Islamism against the
Muslim Brotherhood and against care
which is the Council on american-islamic
relations that are the I call them
terrorists in suits because these are
the front of the Muslim Brotherhood and
care who groomed Allah and brood
Rashidah and many others and by the way
in 2020 we have more care has been
grooming more than 120 Rashida
Ilhan alike when did he move to the
United States so I moved to the United
States in 1993 as soon as I moved I
started working in the media my mother
as well and then I started doing US
media and Arabic and it's so funny
because I was the youngest one well you
know Voice of America and Voice of
America is a federal federal entity so
when I applied for it
there were like 400 something and I just
went and I did my test whatever and and
then a week later I was because there
was only one opening and I got it so
even there I know I liked really but the
first day I was at the office all of
them were so much older than I am and
they looked at me like who is she
uh-huh but the first hour I went on air
everybody came it's like now we can say
welcome to VOA and that was a wonderful
wonderful experience don't forget I came
here I speak English so I came to the US
speaking English so it wasn't that hard
for me
to just be there plus I love the culture
I love this country and it's home it's
that's where my heart is
but I don't understand I I thought we're
told all the time that America is an
evil racist patriarchal state that no
dark-skinned immigrant could come to and
be treated fairly especially if they
come from the Middle East the place like
Iraq something like that oh why are you
telling me that's not true and you if
you love this country and work hard you
might be able to make it so you're
telling me I've been here three decades
it was very easy for me to move
somewhere and live if I didn't like it
why would I stay here if I didn't like
it it's one of the most it's one of the
greatest it's it's the greatest country
in the world and is it shocking to you
as someone that lived under what you
lived under had to do everything that
you just laid out to even get here when
you hear all of this endless ridiculous
craziness about how horrible America is
is it just mind-blowing to you it
provokes me that first of all let's talk
about Ilhan Omar and that's that's very
we were gonna get there there's a lot on
Omar's up here yes because I truly
believe that when you go to a new
country and this country B becomes your
home I mean at least B be grateful that
you you have you live in a country that
you have the right or of every single
American you're no difference than
anybody else you have the right and you
have the duties and and that's how you
should deal with it yet
there are immigrants from different
countries I'm not saying from it or from
that they come here and they don't
integrate with the communities so they
still live in small area that it's
basically they brought everything from
their country and they're not
willing to participate or a willing to
be part of the of the community and
that's where I feel that organizations
and and should work on on these
communities to build bridges to to make
them feel integrated in schools and that
work place and others I mean can you
believe that someone who lives in for 20
years in a country that can't even speak
the language mm-hmm how you mean it's
not racist to say that maybe you should
speak the language of the country you
live in
or at least try to I mean this is
ridiculous racist no this is this is the
country this is the language of this
country you wanna be a part of this
country part of the communities you want
to be you want to provide you want to
fulfill your duties so you get your
rights I mean this is come on I mean at
least speak the language yeah at least
read the sign all right this is
ridiculous okay so we can link all of
this to Ilhan but before we get
specifically into her just tell me a
little bit about what your general
political philosophy is because now that
you're running for Congress obviously
that's it can't just be about I'm
against Ilhan no well is that that but
just tell me a little bit about your own
sort of political beliefs a question
that I've been asked so many times
thinking that all immigrants and there
they should be Democrats I'm a
conservative person I have conservative
principles since I came here so being a
journalist I know exactly what these two
political parties are so it's easy for
me I mean to be conservative and to be a
Republican and that's what I've been
since since I
I came here I truly believe that decency
should be back in our political arena
and our lives will we've lost it we've
lost that and this is this is so bad I
mean they hatred that we see now this
was never the narrative in the United
States yes we disagree but we don't hate
in each other
I don't hate somebody because he's a
Democrat maybe I would never marry a
Democrat we'll be fighting all the time
yeah but an honest politician yeah
exactly but you know what it's sad that
you see in 2020 that hatred there the
toxic narratives coming from the far
left
I wouldn't say coming from the Democrats
in general the the far left and the
progressive that are trying to destroy
this country people don't want this this
country to be a socialist country people
don't want to live in Cuba people don't
want to live in Venezuela people don't
want to live in these countries or even
Russia for this matter so we have people
that are praising these other countries
I mean if you praise it and you like it
so much
go be a senator there yeah or a
congresswoman right well that's what I
always say nobody ever leaves come here
nobody's leaving we're not stopping
people from leaving but they they never
leave so was it seeing what was
happening with the with the far left
progressives and the Socialists is that
really what drove you to get into
politics or was it specifically about
Ilhan and then we'll talk more about her
well being a journalist and I've been
doing it for a long time and I do
foreign affairs and I cover the whole
world and covering wars
conflict zones Human Rights crisis album
terrorist attacks all over the world
especially in Europe I've been there
done that so I know what kind of outcome
would come from a narrative like like
this the oppression be the hatred the
anti-semitism and I think Alan Omar made
the biggest mistake of her life it was
right when she got elected and she
didn't wait for long to bring out all
the ugliness yeah well it was almost
like day one she suddenly flipped on all
of these things even though a lot of us
could see it beforehand obviously yeah
but I'm being there so as a journalist
and I'm I'm very active I'm an a
journalist with a cause and I've been so
active against oppression against
radical Islamism against the Muslim
Brotherhood and against care which is
the Council on american-islamic
relations that are the I call them
terrorists in suits because these are
the front of the Muslim Brotherhood and
care who groomed Allah and brood
Rashidah and many others and by the way
in 2020 we have more care has been
grooming more than 120 Rashidah el Han
alike if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell